suite de notre série spéciale Irlande
qui se termine aujourd'hui Florent
Clavel nous plonge dans l'ambiance de la
Viva Stadium à Dublin pour une rencontre
entre les clubs irlandais de Leinster et
Monster 51
000 places c'est aussi le stade où joue
le 15 du Trèfle à domicile vous aurez un
aperçu de la ferveur des supporters
irlandais qu'on retrouvera durant la
Coupe du monde de rugby et peut-être
aussi autour de leur camp de base à
Tours regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce soir le stade dublinois et ses 50.000
places est à moitié plein
les regards sont déjà tournés vers la
finale de la Coupe d'Europe face à La
Rochelle dans une semaine et pourtant
l'ambiance est au rendez-vous
chaque match ici est une fête et
celui-là a une saveur particulière face
à l'autre rival irlandais du Monster
mon conjoint supporte le lineins
[Rires]
on verra dans deux heures le match
débute et le line Store est dominé de
nombreux internationaux ont été
préservés avec le Monster les Dublinois
forment l'ossature de l'équipe d'Irlande
et même après le premier essai des
Bleues les supporters s'attendent à un
match
âpre voilà c'est dingue c'est ça le truc
Leinster Monster c'est toujours très
serré
mais il y a rien de mieux que ces matchs
c'est l'une des plus belles affiches
dans les tribunes Yann ne manque pas une
passe il est venu avec presque toute sa
famille mon fils mon neveu ma mère est
ici c'est sa première fois à la viv a et
elle a 94 ans à la mi-temps les
supporteurs refont les niveaux ils vont
en avoir bien besoin alors que leur
équipe vient en tête à quelques minutes
de la fin du match ce drop magnifique
des rouges
[Applaudissements]
échoue en demi-finale du United rugby
Championship
il est un peu triste comment ça va
la semaine prochaine contre La Rochelle
oui on est sûr d'y arriver
malheureusement les lineins
s'inclineront aussi face au maritime pas
de quoi décourager des 12000 abonnés du
CLUB qui connaissent la valeur de leur
équipe l'une des meilleures d'Europe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et non ils n'ont pas gagné contre La
Rochelle